foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn how to install SQL server in
the Windows operating system but before
we begin let me tell you guys that we
have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you're a tech geek in a
continuous hunt the latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from simplydown now without
further Ado let's get started with our
unborn agenda that is how to install SQL
server in Microsoft operating system
if you are an aspiring data analyst
looking for online training and
certification from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading industry experts then search no
more simply launch professional
certification program and data analytics
from Purdue University in collaboration
with IBM should be your right choice for
more details use the link in the
description box below with that in mind
go to our PPT so to install SQL server
and windows you will need two different
software packages the first one being
the SQL Server itself and the second one
is a SQL Server management tool let's
download these let's go back to Google
foreign
server
down
now you can choose the first option SQL
Server downloads from Microsoft ensure
that you are choosing the software from
the service provider which is Microsoft
itself not the third party software
files
now if you scroll down you can see two
different versions of the SQL Server the
first one being the developer and the
second one being the express if you are
a learner then I would recommend you to
go with the express version because it
has more features than the developer
version and also it is open source now
let's go with the express version
download now
the software file should be downloaded
shortly
so we express the XE file has been
downloaded successfully click on it and
it should be running
now it is asking for the admin
permission get the admin rights and then
you should be good to go
once you provide the admin rights the
SQL Server installation will begin so
here you can see the window or the
dialog box which will give you three
different options basic
custom and download Media I would
recommend you to go with the basic
version
select that and now read all the terms
and agreements post that accept
and check the location where the SQL
Server is being installed if you're
comfortable with it you can click on
install or if you want to change go to
browse and select your folder I'm
comfortable with this particular
location which is program files so I'll
click on install
it should be installing in a while
there you go the download is successful
the installation phase might take a
little while
so the downward has been successfully
done and the installation has also
completed successfully now only the
first phase of the installation process
is done right the SQL Server is done but
we need another tool which is ssms or
SQL Server management story that you can
get right over here is click on install
ssmv and it will redirect you to a
different web page just click on the
webpage you want to go or the webcast
you want to choose
and this is the webpage that I was
talking about scroll a little
towards them and you can see the option
saying free download for SQL Server
management studio version
19.0.2 so you might be having the latest
versions in the future as well let's go
with the current version click on it
and there you go the system setup is
being downloaded here
it's 629 MB so it might take a while
there you go the Microsoft SQL Server
management Studio has already downloaded
and is being installed right now so now
you can see there is one bottleneck you
need to restart the system or you can
close and start it anyways but let's
choose the restart option
so after the restart the SQL Server
management studio is downloading a few
more packages and the installation
should be done in a while
there you go the installation has been
complete and you have the server
management Studio ready to execute open
that
so here you have the server type server
name and authentication if you want to
change them you can but I'm comfortable
with these and just press connect and
you should be good to go and get started
with you
query editor
then you can start writing your queries
on your SQL Server
with that you've come to an end of this
session on how to install SQL server in
your Windows operating system if you
have any queries regarding any of the
topics covered in this session then do
let us know and our team of experts will
be more than happy to reserve all your
queries at the earliest until next time
thank you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you